but I think the Liberals are becoming
more entrenched or more inflexible
because they know their [ __ ] days a
number hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Francis Foster I'm constant in
kissin and this is a show for you if
you're bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts
our fantastic guests this week is a
journalist and the author of the great
betrayal the true story of brexit Ron
little welcome to trigonometry thanks so
much for asking these thank you it's
great to have you before I go on this is
the book make sure you get it this is
what we were talking about but before
before we get into it for anyone who
doesn't know who you are which is a
small number of people these days just
tell everybody who are you how are you
where you are what has been your journey
through life because we always find that
quite interesting all right okay sure
well I'm a media [ __ ] and I'm a
journalist a hack a columnist for The
Sunday Times The Spectator in the Sun I
once was a speechwriter for the BBC
after that I worked the speechwriter for
the BBC there's a Freudian sin the
Africans who tried it for the Labour
Party after that worked for the BBC and
it found the religion between the two
very easy indeed as you can imagine my
point has always been to to say what I
think people believe but are too scared
to say for reasons of either direct
political correctness or indirect
political correctness is a slight
difference between the two and also to
make people laugh or even less my job is
to is to is to amuse for that I usually
get called a racist and a homophobe
because I have made jokes about black
people before and indeed gay people but
I like to think of myself in a very real
sense as an Equal Opportunities [ __ ] as
someone who will offend everybody
including you know the people I come
from up in the northeast of England and
people who live in Brighton especially
people who live in Brighton and French
people and everyone that they are all in
there I don't think I think everybody
has the right to have the piss taken out
of them including me I think that's a
beautiful thing about the French and
that people say you can take the piss
out black people gay people but French
it should accept the changes you know
used to be like that about the Welsh I
tried that a couple of years ago you
know it wasn't it was one of the least
offensive things I've ever said in my
life I happened to mention that there
was a paucity of vowels in the Welsh
language which isn't a terribly original
observation nor a terribly funny one and
Damon do lolly
and the Welsh language society said it's
important we must stick to freedom of
speech freedom of speech is the most
important thing but we must stop people
generating hate about our language
generating hate about your [ __ ]
knocking the nog language thomas and
your tank engine though the isle of man
isn't it he actually reported to the
police and said can we investigate this
to see if this is a race hate crime
suggesting that there are not many
vowels in the welsh language and the
thing which struck me was that he was
actually the police commissioner for
north wales oh wow and he referred it
and presumably you know he should have
been investigating for waste wasted
police time just so so we'll be careful
within a year or two the French you're
not gonna weigh with the French will be
left with having to pick on tiny
minority countries you know
well I birdie or something yeah Kappa
vetted yeah
cup of it yeah you mispronounce the name
I quite like the you clarified that it
was one specific watchman because
initially you said they called and I
just had this image in my head of like
the whole that's a point yeah and of
course that's because I've got loads of
letters in from people saying from from
people in Carmarthen and Cardiff and
real say God I'm so sorry when did we
lose our sense of humor you know
[Music]
so no II of course not it's that liberal
elite with their vested interests who
desperately desire a sense of victimhood
and I suppose they are victims because
they're thicker [ __ ] well we've started
off with what we were going to talk
about later
why don't we just carry on down this
path absolutely so you you say you're an
equal opportunities [ __ ] and when we and
I read your articles in The Times and I
think they were incredibly funny has
there ever been a point where you've
made a joke that actually you look back
when you think I shouldn't have said
that that was too far over the line
no but there's been at an occasion every
week without fail where I look at
something I've written and think Oh in
the current climate I shouldn't have
written that I wonder if the subs will
take it out or the editor will take it
out and then I think no you've got to do
that if you cannot you cannot be
constrained by this stuff otherwise it
makes you boring and partisan and I try
not to be part is that in my
offensiveness you know it's sprayed
around liberally like Jimmy Savile would
have sprayed around his seed
a pleasant image I mean you're right
what happens actually is my wife reads
my copy before I send it in with a glass
of wine and she reads through it and
she's she's for a quiet life
she says Roger you can't say this I said
why can't I it's true you know it's true
and it's funny what they'll cut it out
and if they don't cut it out the police
will get involved and she's invariably
right but you cannot stop doing that and
yet it is getting more and more the case
that you self-police it gets less funny
it's it's it's more and more the case
every week that goes by I thought we
were at something I mentioned this on a
different program before now I thought
that maybe last year we were at
something called peak wank now it's
still it's getting worse
it's killing words and do you think
there's going to be a backlash because I
talk a lot with comedians we both do and
when you look at something like Dave
Chappelle is released to this new
special Appeals referred to himself as
appeal but yeah yeah of course there is
of course there's that and on the other
side of Stewart Lee who you know I can
remember Stewart Lee ruffling a few
feathers by saying that what's he called
that guy from the driving program that
people using Thaksin he died or his
children which is good comedy which is
good comedy and comedy coming from the
left and driven from the left
they're from the liberal left though I
wouldn't call it a proper left I'm using
now the [ __ ] public school boy when
it comes down to it brilliant there he
is I think you guys are at the forefront
of it I mean constantly the other one
who has to sign a five page document
when you go on stage at a university
because there are so many things which
now are not considered to be funny and
if I may say so you may get away with
slightly more than I because you come
from a from what it's cool to be
identified do this because I would
definitely get me a lot further but also
but of course company against music of
course you're Jewish yeah and I did say
that likely either and so no you guys
have more of the front of it than I am
I mean you know in France this question
this is I think what he's getting at in
terms of the backlash like I did a show
about that contract this year at
Edinburgh and it did very very well with
the public and with a lot of ruse I
obviously got a lot but you know the
Guardian and all these people slammed it
but I got a lot of K that trap Ryan one
star I wish he'd given me a once on what
he did is actually he went to see all
the non work comedian yeah and instead
of giving us a review he did a whole
write-up in which essentially he he
wouldn't actually give any of us a
review he just made a few comments about
it man who knows nothing about commonly
does not have a single like Margaret
Thatcher being a comedy quitting
sorry gone so but my point is that those
of us me Leo Geoff know about a Android
oil who you might know yeah creative
autonomy right
we all did pretty well right so when
Francis is asking about the backlash do
you sense that maybe the peak wanker
point is coming well no I mean in a
sense the reason I didn't is a backer
I think the people are with us
haven't I think these people who tried
to stop us and what we say have power
without hegemony their views are not
shared by the majority of people in the
country remotely but they aren't shared
by the BBC commissioning team and they
are shared by the channel 4 right yeah
and the people who dictate well as you
the words you use the current climate
yes yeah yeah story only yesterday on
the BBC this is Clinton with a
commitment this is Radio 5 Live and it
was about some lesbians having a night
out a nice night out I think it was in
Leeds and a vicious hate crime had been
committed which the police were
reluctant to follow up and really a fact
that I've got themselves where he worked
up on it you found out what exactly had
happened and some drunk blown shouted
hello is this a fat homosexual
contingent then don't say it's not a
hate crime and I think when that is
broadcast with this sense of outrage
it's a horrible thing to say it's not
horrible it's nasty it's it's Pig
ignorant but it's it's not you know get
in the cattle vans is it you know when
that is broadcast as being something
about which we should be viscerally
outraged I think the public listen to
that and think what I don't think they
are anywhere near where the BBC is on
this issue you know I just don't think
they I think and this is where it comes
into brexit where brexit comes into the
picture which is that there is such a
disconnect between this liberal elite
and the country between Parliament in
the country but also between the
judiciary the BBC the civil service and
what we consider the rest of the country
it's
there's just no shared common view of
the world they're at odds with each
other
I think they'd go along to your gigs
enough I think know that they laugh at
the stuff I write but from the man
yesterday in Canterbury Station I
enjoyed reading a Facebook update about
that sometimes they just tell everybody
what happened I go to London sometimes
and read as infrequently as possible and
people come up and say I really love
your stuff thank you please keep writing
it and that'll be will be four out of
five
but one person always walk by and go and
and that's fine yesterday it states that
I was buying a ticket and a youngish
bloke walked by and he just turned to me
when racist in that ovine way that they
have and but it's so intent was in
delivering this gentleman's that he
failed to notice a large door and
smashed into him smashed his face into
it and smashed his arm on the handle and
I just said ago if it had been
appropriate I would have masturbated the
instant camera moments they are
enjoyable it's quite a bit to other
locations in London one was when I was
getting on the understand were too but
Stratford and it was quite crowded tube
was about to go doors were about to shut
and there was this black lady was two
carrier bags and she couldn't and the
doors were better shut I held the doors
open for her took one of the bags and
helped her on this train advise that I
would have expected you to do that
[Laughter]
just utterly bizarre and it was one
other I was walking with I was having
lunch with in the air bungalow wallah
who was at the time the number two or
three in the Muslim Council of Britain
we were having a lunch to talk about you
know Islam and Stefan and I've known him
for years and we were crossing busy road
in I think I think was Hoban area
because it's a very busy road and a
woman ran through the traffic tucked on
in the 'its sleeve and said so there is
this minority which which you know hangs
on its every word you know the Owen
Jones the people with the IQ of Aryan
but I think the vast majority of the
public just thinks this is an annoying
diversion from what we should be talking
about you know at the last election
polling has been done in the States
political correctness was a really
really big reason why Donald Trump won
congratulations USA and you know so when
you talk about a backlash I think people
are averse to it identify whether it's
it back i think they've always been
averse to it they're sick of it how that
expresses itself in the end politically
is a more difficult thing to talk about
we've got some very exciting news Emily
Constantine yes we do I will be doing my
extremely well reviewed and popularly
enjoyed show called all well that ends
well which I did at Edinburgh Fringe
here in London at the Bill Murray comedy
club which is an angel in his Lincoln on
the 16th of November which is a Saturday
at 5:30 and I thought I'd try and create
a contrast between good comedy and bad
comedy so I
invited Frances to emcee as well
absolutely now because he's invited me
we've sold some tickets for the shot we
are also gonna need more of you to come
and support comedy and in support comedy
no there will support me I am comedy and
support Constantine as he delivers his
lecture - no I'm joking
come and watch a show it's going to be
brilliant it's going to feature me at
the top doing a little bit of ten
minutes of banter calling people fat
pricks and then we're gonna bring
Constantine on
yeah we like hypocrisy so it's gonna be
absolutely awesome it's gonna be in
London it's gonna be at the Bill Murray
pub at 5:30 p.m. on what Saturday the
16th of November we'll see you there
[Music]
well let's talk about it because it's
the brexit conversation yeah yeah it
will it is a brexit conversation and I
remember reading one of your articles
and you were talking about how it was
the morning when the results came
through leave vote one and I think it
was you who turned to your wife or your
wife turned to you and said they're not
gonna let this go through are they yeah
and I was it was Lissy who'd been up all
night what because she's a political
junkie and loves elections and so that
was the first night that I was roused
from my sleep at five in the morning get
up Rob get up rod we've done it and
three months later three months later I
was lying in bed
he's done it he was tired
Donald [ __ ] you're right I went
downstairs saw the BBC studios where
they were you know clearly sobbing and
no I can't remember who said it first
but I said they'll never let it happen
and I put that up on Facebook they just
won't let it happen you know the
Liberals hate being gainsaid on anything
so it's not just black said I mean if
you try to get someone who doesn't have
liberal views into a position of power
or even a minuscule position of power
such as we saw with Toby Young and a lot
of scrutiny recently they'll stop that
you know there it's something like all
six degrees of Shami Chakrabarti it's a
game you can play that that all the
quangos and institutions the great in
the good institutions the BBC the third
sector and so on have this very small
coterie of people working for them who
are all appointed I mean they don't have
to go out and turn up for a [ __ ]
interview you know they're appointed
we've invited a lot of them well I think
charmese I think Charlie at one point
was on about seven and you play six
degrees with Shami Chakrabarti just by
going through the various clangers and
you can always link them up you know
like that like the Kevin Bacon thing and
yes I'm an alibi Brown for example who
is a visiting professor at the
University and is on various boards and
so on those are the people who control
our cultural life and they will brook no
argument you know if you are not of
their be n pencil opinion you will not
get anywhere I do not know a single
socially conservative journalist
all right wing journalist you know down
the line conservative which I'm not I do
not know a single one who has been
offered a visiting professorship who has
been asked to be on the board of the
national film theatre or the migration
Advisory Committee
I could do that job it just doesn't
happen
Paul Dacre you know probably the most
successful editor this country's seen
for decades
never no one ever else Fraser Nelson
who's raised the spectators figures 285
I will simply know just incredible
brilliant journalists never asked none
of these people are ever asked Okin
Jones who is [ __ ] as a journalist you
know a seriously awful dermis there are
some good liberal left on this he's not
one of them
and nor is Yasmin I tell you a funny
story about Yasmin in the second well
yeah I don't lose do it's just
that is how our cultural life is
controlled you know and I don't think
people like it I don't think people like
it I don't think people like it either
nothing there's a real resentment to it
and the problem is for me is a lot of
these people live in their bubble where
they interact entirely entirely all they
have is their opinion getting reflected
back to them so when something might
trump or breaks it happens they're in
complete shock oh no you're absolutely
right and that's that's the thing from
the book may be the only time will
mention the book to be honest but I
think it's a most salient of the
chapters which is an awful lot of work
was done after brexit by the horrified
horrified liberal elites saying who are
these ghastly [ __ ] people who voted
to leave and so there was demographers
on him everyone sort of came up with
this same thing which was they were
poorer and less well educated and which
isn't true
nor is it totally true about the poorest
stuff whether they tend to be northern
away from cities which is true and so on
and so on
and yet when you actually look more
closely as a demographic which rented
leave there's nothing really which pulls
it together it's you know an
amalgamation of people with very very
different views in different parts of
the country and different parts of the
social strata you know
I think it's 46% of the a/b group for
example you know that the top social
group voted leave one in three of
university graduates you know they
wouldn't have won without the university
graduates and so on and so on and so on
and the young vote you know it was I
think 50/50 age 25 to 40 it's not as
simple as they put it but what there is
is a very interesting demographic of a
portion of the remain vote
now most remain is I suspect her like us
like you guys you in voted remain yeah
but most of us it was a difficult
decision and we voted one way or the
other and we can talk about it and if
there's not a problem
and do you know people who voted leave
and I know people who voted remain most
of my friends voted remain there is this
tranche of the remain vote I don't know
how much looking at the figures my guess
is somewhere between 20% to 30% I guess
there that's the 29% of remain voters
who befriended anyone on Facebook who
voted leave that's an incredibly high
amount it's really once you know 29%
they defend you just because you had a
different opinion to them and it is it's
the BBC where my estimate is 94 95 said
in favor of well no I said I genuinely
think that's a moderate assessment I
mean there are other ones and you're not
just a guy talking used to work for me
but it's a word for then I I know one
person in the entire organization we
voted leaf and I know three or four
hundred people in the BBC but it's not
just a BBC it's it's the the creative
industries you know Sam West we're all
in mourning
it was something like 96% of the
creative the lovelies
yeah it was 93% of academicians so the
people in charge of our universities it
was 70 percent of teachers and my
guesses and I don't know this for a fact
my guess is approaching 90% in the south
of the country and these are people who
simply never met anyone they really are
like Margaret Thatcher when she was
asked about the poor at the end of the
street on occasions they have never
actually come into contact with people
who voted leave they are entirely
insulated and so that when they say I
don't know anyone who voted leave they
mean it and they're telling the truth
and this this echo chamber that they
live in and this is a great thing about
the brexit vote but it's exposed this
massive divide this incredible distance
which there is between what the american
sociologist charles murray calls the
super elite what John Gray a far better
writer in this country calls the hyper
liberals who simply cannot countenance
argument do not understand where that
argument comes from will categorize that
argument is coming from stupidity real
education and xenophobia wherever it
does occur and are constantly reinforced
did their opinions by everyone else they
[ __ ] work with it is remarkable and
brexit brexit deserves a round of
applause for having opened that to us
because I don't think it was always
there but I don't think it was ever as
clear as it is now and I think the point
you just made is very very true and the
sentence that sums it up is why I hear
all the time from the hyper liberal
Romania's which is not everyone who
voted leave was race I said racist
motive Lee okay but with that don't you
know Billie [ __ ] brag
and I wrote at the time yeah bill yeah
not all [ __ ] by Billy Bragg records but
everyone who's bought a Billy Bragg
record is a [ __ ] I mean no it's
ridiculous and it was exploded you know
within very unusual er by the people see
within two months of a brexit I remember
Adrian Charles to the piece from
Birmingham where he just interview the
people who devoted leave and he said I
don't see so I currently do but I don't
see these people as being these people
aren't racist only racism in it at all
there wasn't an animus against
immigration against immigrants there was
an animus against the process which had
allowed untrammeled immigration number
one there wasn't an animus against
polish people I mean [ __ ] hell were
to the right of us none of that it was
no you know we would like to control our
own borders we think that's a sensible
way to go on and I've never seen their
animus towards black ethnic minority
polish whatever that the left insists is
an integral part only with just it's
bollocks absolute bollocks I'm curious
about your position on this whole thing
because as you said before we started
the interview and you want a
particularly ardent lever know you kind
of voted to leave on the balance of
things but it's likely there are great
reasons to stay in the yeah you know no
question about like what well coming
from the northeast of England the amount
of money that the you ported to the
northeast of England which I think you
know okay we're now in charge of our
finances we can do it will we it's
rather good I think there was something
like
120,000 jobs in the Northeast depend
upon trade with Europe but also
something else I'm really interested in
is science and research and undemocratic
so it may be I think there's something
rather good about having certain funding
ring-fenced from the five-year
parliamentary cycle that can go to stuff
like the jet torus lab in Oxford so that
we can you know maybe find a form of
energy which is clean and virtually
inexhaustible all those things are good
and basically you know I am swayed a bit
by the notion that pieces reigned in
Europe for a long time now as the main
reasons I voted remain well it's it's a
good reason it's a good reason you could
argue that NATO's part of that or you
could argue the trade deals decent trade
but still it still seems to me to have
some force that you know we have had
peace and you know contrary to what
people like Alastair Campbell and Peter
Mandelson would say I feel European you
know I like Europe and particularly
Germanna file okay I loathe France but
[Music]
particularly the parts of Europe which
have more laterally been and joined to
join the European Indians such as you
know Poland and the Baltic States
Hungary and so on I'm sorry I adore
notice it's my culture I think that's
kind of rubbed a little bit by the fact
that I also feel British Anglo Saxon and
therefore some connection with America
you know the first time I went to
America or I felt at home immediately
because it's where all the novels I had
read music and also the Commonwealth for
historical reasons and for decent
historical reasons you know we have a
responsibility so it was a very very
difficult call and I thought it was just
about it was just about in the end the
thing which won it for me was the
European Union that's increasingly
authoritarian attitude towards countries
under its Dominion particularly Poland
and Hungary but also Catalonia its and
its ever-increasing expansionism not
geographically wise but policy wise that
it wished control over all of us and I
would I think the nation-state kind of
works
it's why I'm a social democrat you know
I think the nation-state kind of works
it works for us
I can equally see why if your looks and
British or German for differing reasons
you may have problems about the
nation-state and its power I get that
but we're not them yeah and it's the
thing that nobody really talks about is
how sustainable is you you even if we
remained within it because if you look
at the northern European states and the
southern European states that I mean the
southern European states number one to
put it bluntly a [ __ ] economically and
always [ __ ] were there for the for
the for the spectator about ten ten
years ago now where I said what I'd
really like is a kind of Hanseatic
League that's what I'd like a trading
bloc and I'd I'd get rid of the
Catholics
that's Spain Italy actually parts of
Italy are allowed in Milan is allowed in
cheese's Puran is allowed in Milan it's
not really Italian you go there it's
like it's my ostrich gym exactly so
hard-working northern Protestants and a
few slobs gets accused of being racist
in NRT in his favorite country in Europe
is Germany actually it always struck me
it's true about the racism in a way in
that my objections to the European Union
back in the 90s were racist
in that all or at least left winners
were cool and racist what I thought was
much as you've just said that identity
that Greece Italy and Spain are either
culturally or economically in the same
area as we are I would have them form a
different block you know she's nice
easygoing people who go to sleep at
midday because I and I think I was right
I don't think that cultural difference
has has has ever been a swayed I think
that's still there and of course it was
behind the great crisis with Spain and
Portugal the pigs Portugal Greece Spain
isn't part of this okay and we are
joking of course but isn't doesn't think
you all have to take responsibility in
that that currency has been manufactured
created to suit the Germanic economy and
everybody else who's got you know
economy - it depends on agriculture and
tourism [ __ ] partly partly but the
euro was a bad idea every single opinion
poll in the 1990s which was about
whether we should join a single currency
no and every single opinion poll in the
nineteen nineties about whether we
should stay in the EU always yes and and
you can add into the euro the European
Central Bank which is ineffectual weak
doesn't know what it's doing so yes but
but that's the thing you know that the
rather horrible truth is that one of the
reasons I voted leave reluctantly was in
the hope that if we left Europe the
European Union might be forced to reform
itself a bit
and might shift a little bit more along
the axis which I and by the sound of it
you would prefer now I think I probably
got that wrong but there has been a
change you know we have seen across
Europe populist sfrom both the left and
right people always forget people
without any great populist sacha so you
know it's it's Hitler as everything
that's sort of deferred to these days
referred to these days there's populism
from the left's series here was probably
lism from the left there's a please yeah
well and there's a good argument as well
that the SNP is populism from the left
and corbett for that matter we can come
on to him if you like but no what I
hoped was was we might get back to being
a trading bloc and if you look at the
opinion polls in Europe with the
exception of a few countries and
bizarrely Luxembourg is counted as a
country why is it when this all happened
when Brooks had happened and I I heard
on the radio we were being lectured to
by an Estonian pseudo Finn's yeah I
guess
see there's Candy's good people what I
mean is see the good thing about
offending people from Luxembourg is
they're so few of them it doesn't really
matter
we are where we are what I actually
wanted to talk to you about is I think
they're of agreement between us probably
more than anything is what has happened
since since the referendum because both
Francis and I vote to remain but I I
think anyone with any sense now has to
recognize that well it just doesn't make
sense we have a parliament that refuses
to respect the wishes of the people you
have a prime minister who's now you
could say forced to not respect it which
is a parliament yes we've had a
parliament that is just not
representative of the country at all no
in terms of that crucial issue that's
the only issue there you know what we
need to do we need to rerun the
referendum not the brexit referendum the
AV referent mmm
proportional representation yeah I've
always been first-past-the-post always
mm-hmm but when you look at the House of
Commons now I mean basically the problem
is and always was right for the stylus
it was something in the region of 6 to 1
in favor of remain and every major party
had a majority in favor of remain apart
from the DEP but it's not just that is
it you know it's not just that it said
my suspicion is that an awful lot of the
public but but I think a large
proportion of the public economically
fairly left if they agree with the
nationalization the polls tend to
support higher taxes yeah we can go
along with that improved Society hi
Emily yeah we can do that you can do all
that but essentially quite conservative
and that is not remotely reflected in
Parliament where people are neoliberal
and they're neoliberal on the right in
economics
they're neoliberal in foreign policy
which means we interfere in sovereign
countries and cause murder and mayhem
and they're neoliberal or live or
liberal on social policy to the degree
that the vast majority of people the
obvious
examples of this are on transgenderism
is this a clear and obvious case the the
vast majority of people in the country
are utterly averse and Parliament does
not reflect that the Conservative Party
doesn't reflect it conservative party
for me is mindless towards the
working-class mind us towards cares not
one jot about equality but will make
every possible Cal telling to a liberal
social agenda would you know what a
greens with well I say no one you know
it's a minority that's the big
difference and it's taken brexit I know
I just hope that some people will have
woken up to that you know guys we wanted
to tell you we're very excited to say
we've got a new sponsor which is hello
fresh
indeed we have hello fresh is a UK's
leading recipe box service delivering
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
step-by-step recipes to your door it is
the easy convenient way to cook
delicious dinners from scratch every
single time choose your favorites from
19 recipes every week they have a whole
range of options there for you including
recipes that are ready in under 20
minutes there's family favorites there's
British cuisine there's world cuisine
there's even a five hundred and fifty
calories on the range and that's a great
thing because as you may have noticed in
the time that we've been doing the show
Francis has actually lost quite a bit of
weight so congratulations to him on
going from being massively fat to just
being really fat that's great and if you
want to achieve the same results as
Francis keep eating lard but if you want
to be healthy and slim like me
check out these extra healthy recipes
from hellofresh hellofresh we're
offering trigonometry fans 60 pounds off
four boxes to take advantage of that go
to hello fresh coda UK enter our special
code which is of course trigonometry and
enjoyed delicious dinners without any of
the drama the fresh ingredients come
direct from suppliers i they've been
picked by Constantine's family
you can tell Francis studied geography
at a British school because he can't
tell the difference between Russia
Romania doesn't matter mate same thing
breaks it means breaks it and the great
thing is it's been proportioned for you
so there's no food waste
just like in my home country of
Venezuela the great thing we've had out
fresh is that you're going to be able to
choose from 19 different recipes every
week so there is something for everybody
you're going to be able to eat with you
kids it's going to be no fuss dinnertime
it's gonna be solved yeah I really like
the rapid box which allows you to cook
things in under under 20 minutes but the
great thing about hellofresh as well is
it actually allows you to open up your
cooking range so most households on
average have about six recipes that they
cook regularly hellofresh has up to 19
so you can kind of expand a little bit
in terms of your cooking and of course
they also don't have a fixed
subscription so there's no term you can
cancel you can skip weeks you can change
the size of the box you can change the
livery address you can do all kinds of
stuff to suit your life to enjoy
delicious moments head over to
hellofresh code UK choose your box
choose your delivery slot and add your
favorite recipes discover the easy way
to get delicious dinners from scratch
and if you do that you'll get sick ABS
just like me hello fresh we're offering
trigonometry fans 60 pounds off four
boxes to take advantage of that go to
hello fresh taco de UK enter our special
code which is of course trigonometry and
enjoyed delicious dinners without any of
the drugs
[Music]
but it doesn't seem that anybody's woken
up to him fight he just seemed that
what's happened is that people are
becoming more entrenched and more
inflexible
well the Liberals are but I think the
Liberals are becoming more entrenched or
more inflexible because they know their
[ __ ] days are numbered I mean I
really do think they think that if you
look at the none of the specifics of
ethology in the UK but just the
generality of it across Europe the trend
has been towards people who wanted no
more immigration he aren't terribly keen
on you know the the personal politics
identity politics social issues don't
want any of that stuff that's been the
trend of the last eight to ten years and
it's getting more and more now it's xm25
back people who we mine always liked
such as Uncle Vic in Hungary and and
those countries are being bullied by the
European Delian over this but I think
there's a there's an overwhelming
feeling in Europe at the moment and it's
growing and growing and which doesn't
mean that they want to leave the EU
necessarily but they want it to be a
different beast and they wish this this
liberal liberal elite to be lifted from
their shoulders I'm sure they think that
I'm sure is in there but to my mind if
you've got this whole raft of people who
are the people who go to university were
the people who go to Oxford and
Cambridge and you're never gonna get rid
of them you're very difficult how are
you gonna do it we're talking about
Gramsci in the march through the
institution's yes we're talking a bit
about herbert muck who's er it is very
very difficult i can tell you how we do
in russia occasions where russia has a
point
hmm not many but the BBC for example is
good some good examples BBC has done a
brilliant job in the last
20 years of becoming more diverse
ethnically when I joined the BBC you
would broke up soon as you would go
through seven floors of exclusively
white people to go to the canteen on the
eighth floor whether it was all black
yeah
that's changed and it's good that it's
changed it's good could we not try some
sort of legislation to ensure that this
diversity of opinion should it not be
necessary for our big news and current
affairs programs to have a kind of broad
sweep of opinion on there particularly
given that we all pay for them given the
wheel pay for them you know so they
should be encouraged to have diversity
of opinion rather than this monolithic
culture which she has at the moment
Islands I don't see that's a problem now
what do you do about universities could
you do the same thing I think you
probably can and the universities think
universities have always tended to the
left generally but as we know from the
statistics they've become more and more
left-wing it's now so in the region of
95 percent I think that in the US and
it's Democrat a few things have fed into
that one of them is the fact that so
many people go to university now to do
utterly [ __ ] fatuous degrees almost
always in social sciences yeah that's
been the big growth area wank which will
cost these poor kids 40,000 quid you
know to come away from the Queen Mary
University or the University of
Westminster University of Westminster
with a degree in gender wank I mean it
would be more interesting to deal with
the teachers as well because it's
another area where again there is
heading towards close to unanimity of
opinion and I spoke to a lad who
quotes him in the book who voted leave
you know and he was a teacher of the
school in London and the hatred he got
from colleagues I just incomprehensible
hatred you know how did how the [ __ ] do
you attack that how do you stop that
there was a headmaster of a school in
Dulwich who said that if any people in
this school said anything similar to
what Donald Trump had been saying about
immigration they would be expelled so
this is mad you know and I don't know
what you do about that I mean close down
the [ __ ] teacher training colleges
you know just what the [ __ ] do they
learn there you know and I think the
growth of some of the free schools it's
an antidote to that had Catherine Birbal
sing on the show Catherine bubbles sing
should be our educational policy should
be dictated by Catherine bubbles soon
and Tony Sewell mmm yeah Tony is Tony's
a great mate and their lovely bloke and
he would make a brilliant education etc
so with Catherine that's what you need
yeah and just get rid of this flaccid
self-serving and contradictory toss that
the kids are told at the moment because
this is a great thing about and it's why
liberalism is falling apart that these
identity policies and policy of politics
stuff is it's all mutually contradictory
and it falls apart you suck at the one
little thread of it and it falls apart
like a mohair jumper knitted by the
village idiot which we saw with the
protests in burning all about sex
education in school yes yeah and it's
interesting because I'm a teacher I was
a teacher for a living you feel sorry
but one thing I found very interesting
is how identity politics has actually
started to infect teacher training so
for instance we
to a course and one of them was about
how to teach black boys why and then you
had to treat them differently No
and so this is where totally sold would
change the world and the thing is I'm
sitting there going well this is just
basically racism because you're looking
at somebody and you're not actually
thinking you know what their
capabilities are how academic they are
thinking they're black you're thinking
they're black they're male therefore we
have to treat them differently
two things on that I mean you're
absolutely right it's racist Tony was
picked up on it a long time ago so when
he first came when I first notice ago
when there was a kind of Seacole mania I
don't know if you remember it but it was
a time when Mary see every building in
Britain had to be named Seacole house
because here was a black woman who would
be an aspirational figure for black
students Antonio said why should they
aspire to be a [ __ ] nurse what just
because she's got black skin why
shouldn't they aspire to be Faraday or
Shakespeare why do they why why it's
it's all of this stuff is racist it is
racist it is it is it is letting down
you know a community which could have so
much more to aspire to than this and
corralled into this perpetual state of
victimhood and it just come on it's
crippling it's crippling because what
you're saying is that you will never be
capable of doing all the other children
that's right we need to put in special
provisions we have ceilings also a form
of narcissism because look what I'm a
good person
oh that's right it's virtuous it well
yeah that's right and but we're also
doing it with boys and we had one
training session where we had a teacher
training person come in tell us how boys
can be expected to write a desk for
longer than 15 minutes they needed to
have a break and it's it's miss yeah and
then you know they have to do small
targets in order to keep them engaged
it's bollocks I have to
problems with my daughter's at a grammar
school she passed her eleven plus of
course I mean it has got my genes
and identity politics and the propaganda
is now in kinder every subject apart
from maths and physics it's in geography
English it's everywhere when you study
of mice and men by Steinbeck you are
asked what does this tell us about
sexism in nineteen fifties nineteen
thirty's informed his blood you know
nothing about the book it's about it's
all corralled into the to this this
monomaniacal hierarchy of victimhood and
it's it's terribly debilitating but as I
say I mean the good news is it is
falling apart you know believe me the
transgender stuff the fury of the
lesbian community and the feminist
community and to an increasing degree
the male gay community it's all
beginning to fall apart at the edges
because of course it has to because you
can't build a world like that where it's
all about computing victim hurts it's
it's an absurdity why do you think it
has been so tremendously successful do
you think it's because we are naturally
wired for empathy and so when someone
claims victimhood we are naturally drawn
to go oh would you feel bad therefore I
should try and take your concerns into
account even if they're not necessarily
based in reality in certain instances do
you think that's it I think that may be
why some people that's a good
explanation of why some well-meaning
middle-class people may feel that but I
think the most of it devolves from the
notion that the capitalism is bad which
it may be that it's run by white males
who are therefore bad that it
the Cold War comes into it political
alignment comes into it basically that
we are the white oppressive state and
everyone else is de facto subjugated I
mean I remember back in 1980 83 84
beginning to see this I think that's
what it began late seventies early
eighties when the National Union of
Journalists were advised by the
Commission for racial equality that
henceforth henceforth Chinese people
should be described as being black I was
on the far left at this point I thought
what the [ __ ] and in various places
around London and Manchester various
people but this was an attended and it's
it's the root of it all to say that the
Chinese people are objectively black
because they are subjects of an
oppressive white state and everybody and
it's why Peter Tatchell who I respect as
a guy normally and get on with terribly
well will sometimes say to me Muslims
and gay people or to try and make common
cause against the oppression which
they've suffered Society right I
wouldn't go up any tall buildings very
moral
yeah you know and he was the guy who
stood up for the Irish Baker's the
Northern Irish bakers he pollution
freedom of speech he is a good man but
there is his blind spot you know we are
all victims we are all victims you're
evicted because my mom's from Venezuela
so I do almost yes she [ __ ] is you
can drink now for you as a trigonometry
I mention it every episode night she
[ __ ] hates him yeah she loves Trump
because Trump is the only one who's
actually doing something yeah but she
despises you know but it's their thing
of what we are all victims we're all
victims yeah and and the other
fascinating thing if you've got time to
talk about rating thing it's a bit like
with charities that you begin by saying
that you're a victim that these people
in society are victims and who set up
charities who set up legislation
charities begin to work for legislation
legislation is enacted to protect those
people but it becomes an industry and
what always happens is that it expands
so that for example with disability at
one point there is absolutely no
question that disabled people in this
country had a really really bad run of
it
probably still do in many cases
what happens is and it's the same with
gays stuff as well
it's no longer enough to say that this
is a persecuted minorities any you have
to say it's not a minority did you know
that one in three people are disabled
well no they're not but that's what the
disabled the disability lawyer will tell
you yeah and there are now invisible
disabilities and people who are
depressed will get free parking did you
know that no oh yes free parking for
people who are depressed we're all
[ __ ] depressed
are we not but but it's the same as the
gay lobby as well which is undoubted
horrible discrimination but it's not
enough it's we don't just want to that
is it's 1 in 3 people are gay or what in
4 people no they're not you know you
don't have to do that but that's what
we've done with all of this stuff it
expands exponentially until we are all
victims we could all be disabled if we
want to be
I could register is disabled now you
know my eyesight's not brilliant
I'm from Middlesbrough we could all
register now and that's what we've done
we're trying to make everyone victims
it's bizarre
it is bizarre and to because I was going
to move on to do I was just gonna say
I'm curious still to prod you more on
why you think that idea of victim has
been so successful because that is a
huge transformation because we like
being victims but but here's the thing
right is 40 or 50 years ago we had an
aspirational culture you what you were
taught to be strong particularly if you
were a man you were taught to be strong
you were taught to be resilient you were
taught that your job as a human being is
to face the challenges that life throws
at you the movies that we would watch so
the Sylvester Stallone in Rocky saying
life hits harder than anything you ever
imagined but it
by keeping I mean conned by a culture we
were being combed back then by a by a
paternalistic patriarchal but I think
there's also something appealing in in
that we are all victims I think
everybody likes it these power its power
this parent it and yeah yeah but I'd
also cachet yeah you know my daughter's
school you know as soon as you start
talking about transgender is more
pansexuality or gray sexuality and all
the other sexualities here they're all
certainly not for them you know I'm
different
I'm like that whereas I at school when I
was trying to be different with strip
naked and stand like Jesus Christ in
front of people and scream that they
would be sent to hell which I thought
actually took a bit of doing
yeah you know it's just identifying
something suddenly your career makes a
lot of sense an easy get out and say
responsible for what's right oh it's a
condition syndrome as well yeah
everything is a condition ADHD and I
mean the two obvious ones are ADHD and
dyslexia yeah you know it's very very
difficult to tell the difference between
scientifically between someone who's
dyslexic and someone middle-class mum
and dad you know ADHD no you're a little
[ __ ] if you were wondering why there's
so much swearing in this episode we
unlike with other guests so here we get
a cup of tea or a coffee we got right a
glass of wine
hence the ensuing chaos oh no
come on just layman for me he was honest
and decent on brexit for a while
against his better interests he was
principled he's thick of [ __ ] I mean we
know this to Easi a level Jesus yeah
sure but also I mean there's there is no
imagination or I don't think he's read
properly I don't think he reads things
and you know it's an indulgence his
existence in the labour party was an
indulgence much as I was indulgent in
1976 when I joined the Socialist Workers
Party I knew at 16 that we weren't going
to hand out weapons at I CI and take
over the country you know it was a bit
of fun all that lot are stuck in that
pre-adolescent mindset it is it is
astonishing
Simon Evans has this great joke in his
new show where he talks about how he
talks about all the different
politicians and make fun of both sides
and then he goes with Jeremy Corbyn of
course he started and student politics
where he remains to this day and it's
it's the [ __ ] affluent who fall for
it that being said I know quite a lot of
people in London and and try to work
this out psychologically who vote for
Jeremy Corbyn and then pray he doesn't
get in you know that that is kind of the
lefty virtue signalling writ large as
well on that happy note rod we've got
just one more question for you yeah
which is what is the one thing that no
one's talking about that we
ought to be talking about animal rights
yeah I'm sorry I'm I'm so sorry I'm
really really dull on animal rights
they're gonna have to cut this
I think animal rights is one of the
biggest foods would I there's two things
there's rights for working-class people
who I don't class in the same group as
animals so it's two things I think we
need identity politics for the working
class and I also think we need to I
think we need to clamp down on the abuse
of animals raised for food and if anyone
ever suggests bringing back a fox
hunting bill they should actually be
shot through the head I have a kind of
bulb gun or a rail gun if you seen any
rail guns which are so those two things
those are so you think we need identity
politics for the working class rather
than just moving away from identity
politics in general I always be the bit
flippant okay by and large that's the
one identity which is never idea no it
isn't it isn't but my point is I think
we need to remove identity politics wing
sure Roger that cause to do yeah of
course you do you do yeah I just think
one concern for me with identity
politics is it pushes people who are not
represented by it into their own
identity and then you suddenly get you
know 10 million straight white men going
oh yeah well we are discriminated
against because we're straight white men
that's not gonna end very well no but
that'll happen what that's my point that
will happen which is why I shouldn't
think when you don't sure sure I mean
it's actually a quote from Morris when a
Morris classmen who says you know the
Labor Party has all this identity
politics but none of it about the people
it was set up to represent yeah and that
that's roughly where I'm from which is
why you should vote the Social Democrats
that kind of not on me is it
Yeah right thanks for my so much for
coming on
check out rocks columns as you can see
is an edgy and very funny man with some
very good ideas as always follow us
because you're not on social media I
know this for a fact right yeah yeah
Paulie was a broad on Facebook he's
pretty active on there on Twitter yeah
yeah yeah you'd get canceled very
quickly which would be great for your
career
okay do you know what being canceled it
kicked off because oh no no being
canceled is like where people start
calling for you to be removed from your
newspaper not being allowed to write
anymore like oh they do that already
yeah but on Twitter that that would be a
lot better so you should definitely get
on it okay thank you yeah so when rod
gets on Twitter follow him on Twitter as
always follow us at trigger pod and all
the social media we're going to a very
quick outro and we will see you in a
week from now thanks for watching guys
as always subscribe to the YouTube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger pod and
also leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word
[Music]